hey guys my name is Jess it is the 14th
of March today and you're watching games
but news he's the good stuff was it has
revealed the first eight new cards
coming within half stones third
expansion whispers of the old gods the
new cards include corrupted versions of
classic cards such sloot order and steam
sale and the crop did you say is a
uniquely part-time 7745 munnar there is
also the eater of Secrets a full mana 24
which destroys all secrets and get
buffed 11 for every secret destroyed
that one should be a big worry for
paladin secret decks there are also full
legendary cards being introduced to
carry the theme of godly evils awakening
from their slumber one of which is
confirmed a 10-6 6 with a unique battle
cry that can be buffed before it's
deployed with visible God's is due out
in late April or early May and 134 new
cards are expected to arrive with it but
Thursday has revealed a brand new
trailer for fallout force at Omicron DLC
and revealed release date the DLC will
center on a character called the
mechanist who has unleashed a horde of
robots hell-bent on attacking everything
in sight you'll then hunt down robots
and harvest their bits to build your own
customizable robot buddy automaton will
cost you nine dollars 99 and will be
released for ps4 xbox one and pc on
march 22 the dlc also introduces new
armor abilities and weapons Oh Tommy
John will be followed up by the
wasteland workshop and for Harbor DLC
packs releasing in April and May
respectively you can get access to all
three through the fallout 4 DLC pass
which recently increased in price 250
bucks finally Microsoft is saying what
any of us you've had to choose between
consoles or friendship groups of 12
here today in that they want ps4 and
xbox one to connect together alone
Microsoft has said they will natively
support cross-platform play between Xbox
one Windows 10 and other courts online
multiplayer networks this opens up the
xbox live platform so it can accommodate
players on sony's playstation network
among others chris charla director of ID
at xbox made the announcement on
xbox.com he explained it's up to game
developers to support this feature
adding the blaze will always have the
option of choosing to play only with
other xbox live players the first came
to support the functionality will be
psionics is rocket League which will let
Xbox one and PC players matchmake
against each other Microsoft have
extended an invitation for other
networks to participate as well the BS
boreth previously had met making
capabilities with pcs with games like
portal 2 street fighter 5 and rocket lee
let me know down in that comic books on
how you feel about cross-platform play
and be sure to head to gamespot well
we've got stories on Titan for coming to
origin access and the division server
maintenance that's everything I help you
today as always let me know what matter
to you and I will see you again tomorrow